what is going on everybody welcome to
part 2 of our django tutorial series in
this tutorial we're gonna be talking
about how to add another app basically
because our website right now doesn't
really have anything we've got our kind
of main hub going on but we don't have
any apps and as we said before a website
is a combination of apps so we need at
least one app so that's what we're going
to do here now in the last tutorial we
started off with running the server my
server is still running so to break that
server you can do control C and then
I'll put you back into that my site
directory now we're going to do is we're
going to reference that managed up pi
again i explicitly reference python but
you can pry just do python manage pi or
even python 3 manage pine-sol on i'm
just gonna hit the up arrow because
actually we just referenced manage that
pi we're not going to run server instead
we're going to start app and then you
can give this application anything you
want like any name that you want i'm
just going to call it web app so the
idea here is in any interest of keeping
things as simple as possible yet also
useful the first thing that we're going
to do is just build like a personal
website and the personal website will
have some you know about me page and
then like a blog that you can post on
something like that
and then from there we can go on to make
a much more complex web site possibly
but for now we'll keep it pretty simple
yet actually end up with something
somewhat useful hopefully for you in the
end
so now we've created we've done the
start app web app let's go ahead and
move this over and i'm currently in my
site in my site which is that central
hub let's go back in directory and now
you should have a new one called web app
let's go ahead and click on that and you
should see here actually we've got
migrations in it up hi admin apps models
tests and views so we've got a few extra
things that we didn't quite have in that
original my site so in its same reason
it's treated as its own app admin is for
administration stuff we'll leave that
for now apps we can open this up real
quick
right now and probably in the nearest
future this will never be edited or
won't be edited then models this is what
contains database information as well as
just some simple metadata tests is one
of those things I was talking about
before where Django just makes you do it
the right way you don't have to do tests
but what tests are is like let's say
you've got a login form okay and you've
got users logging in and you sanitize
input because you don't want someone to
do an SQL injection or something like
this a new update comes out and suddenly
we find out there's some other things
that we have to do to sanitize input so
you change that and then lo and behold
you change that and then like a week
later you find out users aren't able to
register because some something broke in
your registration process well that's
the whole point of tests so on you have
two choices if you want to be proactive
against or two main choices or these
there's two main things people do to be
proactive against this first they make
changes and then what they do is
manually run through every process well
when you're just starting let's say you
just have a forum okay well you only
have so many processes register login
forgot password post edit pose something
like that okay there's only a few but
let's say you've got a large website
with a lot of functionality there's a
lot of things that can go wrong for
every single update so what tests do is
every update you make everything you do
you write a test in here a test class
let's say and it's just some code that
will run through a registering logging
in editing every time you run a test
that way you have to do it manually
it'll just run through and test it for
you so this file will actually probably
by the time your website's complete it
would be a very big ugly file but a
super useful time-saving file so I'll
let people think you know making tests
is a waste of time you're not actually
developing or creating anything new but
it actually will save you a lot of time
in the end but we'll leave that for now
that's we will talk about how to make
your own tests don't worry
and then you've got views this is just
how what the user sees basically so
Django is a Model View controller
you've got your models your views and
the URLs that pi is your controller so
let me pull up a picture here so in the
past our previous picture in the last
tutorial was just this with the web
project and then all your sub apps
basically we can now kind of populate
that a bit more and you'll see why in
this tutorial so the main website has
its own URLs PI you've seen it but it
currently doesn't really do much so
you've got your URLs PI which controls
and it links to all the other apps in
your project or all of the apps in your
project and each app has a will have at
least doesn't currently have a URLs dot
pi by default but it will have URLs up
high and then you've gotta move the
picture you've got models views and so
every app will consist of that and just
below it you can see URLs at PI just
controls what's served models is your
database structure and your made edit
metadata and then views is basically
what the end user winds up seeing the
reason why we do things this way rather
than say the flask way at least at the
basic like flask you could do a Model
View controller paradigm with flask
nothing stops you from doing it you just
have to do it yourself okay but what
Jango does is it just has it built in
place for you
so the reason for that is so you can do
something like this you've got one at
website right and it has an app of a
forum but maybe you want another website
that is just a forum or something you
can literally just like take that exact
app and move it right on over to your
other website and on that same kind of
thread you actually can download other
people's apps and use them really quick
really easy so that's why this Django
paradigm just makes a whole lot of sense
to use so moving along we need to go
ahead and get started making our own
basically connecting this app so every
time you start an app what do we do from
there well first of all if we come over
here to our settings here well we should
see you'll scroll down to installed apps
that it just simply doesn't exist here
we don't actually have
this our our new app basically just is
not here so the first thing that you
might want to do is just add web app
there are a couple things that you can
do here the easiest thing that you can
say is just web app just add it that way
so we'll go ahead and again this isn't
that my site okay
my site slash settings just add web app
comma and you're good to go these other
things are just defaults you could
remove some of these I suppose but you
might as well leave them these are
things that you're just almost certain
to use and there are other apps that
come with Django that are not just
default installed so there's a lot of
stuff that comes with Django in fact the
the unofficial mascot of Django here it
is is a pony okay and the idea here and
the reason why was because when as
Django was coming out and really it's
still true today everyone just keeps
asking for feature after feature after
feature and eventually just became a
saying like and no you can't have a pony
all right and P because people just
wanted everything okay and so it kind of
became the unofficial mascot of Django
for this late you know flying pink pony
because of basically all the feature
requests that people were making but in
Django's defense they have a lot of
features they have pretty much honored
quite a bit of those feature requests so
and that's why we have such an
impressive high level framework that we
do so anyways we've installed web app
wow that was such an easy installation
um so we've got web app installed and
now what we want to go ahead and do is
first of all while we're in this my site
directory we got to go to the URLs pi so
this is that main controller right so it
leads to everything as you can see
currently the only thing it leads to is
the starting of admin and there is no
end so remember how I said that the URL
patterns generally at least at the most
basic level are going to consist with a
caret which begins that and then they
end with a dollar sign if you want to
end it you'll notice there is no dollar
here so there is no necessary ending to
this URL all we know for sure is it's
going to point to admin site URLs you
can kind of think of admin site as
it's own app because that's exactly what
it is okay so it's just it this URL is
just saying hey if if the pattern begins
with admin / but doesn't end with
anything yet it could end but it doesn't
have to end here let's check out the
admin site URLs dot PI file and see what
it says as far as where we go from there
so now we're going to add our own and
this one will be basically the same
let's just copy this let's take this
copy paste so it's a URL it's not to
admin but it's going to be the web app
let's just say and we are not going to
use Adventist URLs instead we're going
to say is include and we're going to
include the following file and that's
just could be web app dot URLs so this
includes that web app dot URLs file and
it'll be that URLs PI that doesn't exist
yet but we're about to make it so what
it'll do is when someone goes to your
website slash web app it's then going to
say ok cool now that we're here we need
to consult web app dot URLs to figure
out what what view we need to serve up
for the user now we're using this
keyword include which we don't actually
have yet so right over here Django Kampf
dot URLs import URL the other thing we
need to import is include ok that's it
there so we're fine so let's go ahead
and save that and the next thing that
we're going to go ahead and do is we
want to go to will close out of this and
now we need to go into that new app that
web app and the first thing we're going
to do is we're going to serve a view
here so let's go ahead and edit this
views edit and in here we're gonna have
a few things let's see if we had yeah we
actually have render but we're not going
to use render here we're going to use a
simple response so we're just for now
we're going to say from Django HTTP
import H capital H TTP capital R oh my
gosh I did it twice response and then
we're going to define index and then the
parameter here is requests why I cannot
type too
and what we want to return here is a
simple HTTP response and here you can
just write in HTML this is not how you
will normally do it but it's just what
we're going to do just to make this very
short it'll be just a big hey in the
heading two tags so that's our view for
this index request so that's the view
now how do we control that view to show
well we use URLs dot PI for this so
that's our views and now we need a URLs
PI we don't actually have one so I'm
just going to just take use copy/paste
call it URLs now we're going to open it
and it needs to not be the views but
what we're going to say here for this is
going to be from Django comte URLs
import URL so that's how we specify URL
pattern and then from . import views
period is a relative import basically
we're just importing from the current
package okay so that's how we can keep
things very dynamic so we're just
importing views locally Bator so they're
relatively not locally URL patterns is
now going to equal this can well it's
going to be a list in our case here and
then the URL pattern that we want to
reference is just going to be a URL and
the URL will be it's a regular
expression and it starts and ends so
this would be basically an index
there's nothing here it's just starting
and that's that that's the URL pattern
and if that is the URL pattern it's
going to return the views dot index so
that is here views is this this file dot
index is this function what is it doing
it's returning this response so close
out of that
applause here we go it returns views dot
index and then we can we'll give it a
name for now that's well it needs a name
space so yeah so name is index okay so
once we've done that we should be all
set I might be forgetting something but
we'll save that close that and if I am
forgetting something
we'll get in there and then we can
explain why those errors are so useful
so we'll bring back over the terminal
the server is not running so I'm just
gonna hit up arrow up arrow so python
managed up i run server go ahead and l
we probably need to let's see we'll see
what it says
you have unapplied migrations but
probably is okay so first of all let me
pull down so we visited the home page
that basically this is the index of the
website and it says 404 page not found
and then it goes through and tells you
exactly what it looked for it looked for
the following things to be in the URL
either looked for the starting of the
URL the admin / or the starting of the
URL to be web app which if we go into my
site and then my site and open up that
urls pi file again this is that main hub
that's exactly what it did right
it went through these URL patterns and
said hey does this URL have admin / nope
does it have web app / nope so it
returns a 404 now what if we say okay /
web app okay sure enough we get hey
sorry free headphone users we go hey and
actually find out that indeed we
actually did not get any errors so we
actually did it right the first time
through yay
and we got that message so what happened
in this case was it did the URL began
with web app slash so it said okay web
at slash when it saw that it says okay
we need to include web app dot URLs so
it said all right that's fine and dandy
so it went back here and went to web app
it went to URLs open that up and it read
it and it said okay what's going on here
well this is just it begins and it ends
so what happened it's returning this
views dot index with the name of index
so then it went here to views dot index
and it returned the following view which
was this and just an HTTP response with
hey okay you're welcome I didn't yell
this time
so that's just a really basic example of
you know starting an application and
connecting that application because
again that's how the Django app actually
works it just connects these
applications based on the URLs and
initially when I started out with Django
I was somewhat confused because to me it
just doesn't really make that much sense
to have multiple URLs PI and what makes
it nice though is you could take now you
let's say web app is a really epic
application you could take web app and
include it and another website and web
app can be like for example like let's
say you included another application so
the word on my site URL sup PI and
instead of it being corresponding to web
app you want it to correspond to a GGG
okay or something like this you could
save that and then what what you could
do is you could come over to your new
app and now we can refresh an actual
let's just go GGG and you'll see that it
corresponds there so so you can include
this in any of your other packages you
just have to click and drag it in right
and then if it has models you have to
migrate but we're not going to worry
about that right now
we'll talk about that very soon but if
it has a database net needs you have to
migrate but if it doesn't all you have
to do is basically you just bring it in
and then you have to come over to your
main my site your settings and install
the application but let's be serious
it's not really installing it's just you
know you type in the word and boom it's
done okay so hopefully that was a
bite-sized chunk of Django if you have
questions comments concerns whatever
feel free to leave them below I'll be
happy to help you out where I can
otherwise stay tuned the next tutorial
and thanks for watching